what was your approach to shooting
because you do have some great scenes
there where you know you are shut down
you're walking across the street on
Grand Avenue in LA where you're you know
upset because you've you've been denied
certain things but what's your approach
to shooting because some of the time you
were not allowed access mm-hmm not want
to go there okay I just like get out of
my way I'm gonna get this footage and
you know the guards come out and
everybody you know it's like okay am I
gonna go to jail today or am I gonna
just go quietly but it was more like
like I said you know emails phone calls
and just being in a point of like we got
it we got to keep going the approach
basically was you know I would see a
backdrop if I was interviewing at the
courthouse we had a great scene where
the young man didn't see his dad for
like 18 years you know that was poppin
and it was like I don't know how that
happened and they were there at the
courthouse 18 years later and his mom
finally decided what you all were going
to he's going to go to college let's
just resolve this and they figured out
that they could remove the case from
court but the lawyer told them don't
worry about it you you can see your son
18 years when he's 18 years old I mean I
was crazy yeah and when he was there
he's like you know I'm just so happy
that I finally get to see him and we
caught that on camera so there was that
what there was no approach it was just
like we were there at the right time and
it was like we caught what we needed to
catch
you